[Musique]
chaque mois à la rédaction vous propose
un dossier à d'actualité bienvenue pour
ce premier dossier est de la saison il
est question aujourd'hui de restauration
scolaire nos députés ont décidé de
s'attaquer à ce qui se trouve dans nos
assiettes le 26 septembre dernier une
commission d' enquête parlementaire voté
son rapport qui déclarait la guerre aux
additifs aux aliments trop sucrés trop
salés ou transformer la malbouffe un
enjeu de santé publique mais nous avons
voulu savoir
elle si l'alimentation de nos enfants
étaient aussi équilibrée alors ce qu'il
restait le midi à la cantine
que mangent nos enfants qui sont
inscrits à la restauration scolaire nous
sommes allés à dans des écoles primaires
des collèges des lycées à l'université
c'est le dossier de la rédaction il est
signé nicolas landry à mélanie poquet
grégory canale et marylène yapi chinois
[Musique]
à magny les hameaux ce midi au menu pour
les enfants rient chou fleur et viande
bien loin de celle caoutchouteuse chanté
par carlos en 1972 depuis 2011 la
commune a choisi de passer au bio pour
les 90 % d'élèves scolarisés déjeunant à
la cantine n'a voulu passer à avoir une
une restauration de qualité et 50 % de
bio
donc ça veut dire un produit laitier
donc à chaque chaque repas et soit la
viande soit le poisson soit le
un légume enfin après le deuxième
produit au choix de sodexo puisque c'est
le dax au qui a remporté le marché à
cette époque du bio mais aussi du
circuit court les laitages comme les
yaourts ou les fromages viennent de
fermes locales comme celle de victhom de
jouer en josas et de coubertin à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse favoriser les
circuits courts pour notamment
sensibiliser au goût redonner du goût
c'est aussi l'objectif de trappes
la commune a choisi d'avoir une cuisine
centrale pour produire chaque jour 2000
repas pour ses cantines pour maîtriser
entièrement toute la chaîne de
fabrication pour maîtrisez également les
produits de base qui sont transformés et
savoir ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette de
l'enfant la qualité bio c'est déjà un
label reconnu
même si tout n'est pas parfait dans le
bio il ya quand même une avancée
positive intéressante à poursuivre et
aujourd'hui nous arrivons à avoir des
menus entier composé de bio et parfois
dans le mois des matières des matières
comme les yaourts et fromages
entièrement bio fabriqués dans le
département plus d'un million d'euros de
budget est consacré par la commune à la
cuisine centrale
chaque jour les 13 membres de l'équipe
arrive à 7 heures pour préparer le repas
des 30 office près de 780 kg de produits
sont cuisinés des produits issus
principalement du circuit court et bio
en fonction des saisons
tous les produits sont réceptionnés
entre deux et trois jours avant la date
de production
nous produisons le matin nous
conditionnement donc nous sommes dans en
liaison froide donc une production ne
cuisent on nous refroidit son
avec les normes donc
les normes d'hygiène nous mettons en
barquettes et livrons le
le matin pour le midi donc des repas qui
sont fabriqués la veille trappe souhaite
aussi que l'enfant puisse choisir ce
qu'ils mangent pour cette rentrée la
commune propose dans des écoles pilotes
un double choix pour le plat chaud
[Musique]
il est 10 heures dans la cuisine du
collège mozart de bois d'arcy cathy
gastrin chef de cuisine prépare un
beurre blanc une sauce pour accompagner
le dos de cabillaud ou la côte de veau
avec des pommes de terre le menu destiné
aux 600 élèves de l'établissement une
réduction de vin blanc avec de riches
allocs ensuite qu'on monte au beurre
avec du beurre frais c'est pour
accompagner le poisson qui est un deux
camions aujourd'hui avec des pommes de
terre à la vapeur
on travaille avec le conseil
départemental sur une plateforme on est
on choisit nos produits là entre autres
c'est du surgelé passe quand une
collectivité en grosse quantité nous
surgery sur nos cousines ombre
home hâtivement parce que c'est ce qui
va faire baisser nos
court par le fait des peluches et des
carottes le matin et de déraper sur
place ça nous arrive de faire des
salades des deux lentilles au lieu de
faire une vinaigrette normal base de
moutarde
bah on va faire une vinaigrette à base
d'huile de noisette et de vinaigre de
pomme cuisinés sur place avec des
produits livrés tous les deux jours
cette personne travaille aux côtés de la
chef de cuisine pour l'aider notamment à
recevoir les livraisons il ya de la
civette des tomates de la menthe fraîche
et du persil parce que moi prévus au
menu un taboulé libanais les yvelines
consacre 40 6 millions d'euros pour la
restauration scolaire avec des modes de
fonctionnement différent entre les 116
cantines des collèges d'illinois
aujourd'hui le département souhaite
harmoniser sa gestion avec la création
d'une société d'économie mixte à
opération unique les deux tiers du
capital de cette société seront détenus
par l'entreprise qui va avoir la
responsabilité de la fabrication mais
elle ne sera pas délégataire comme on le
fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire elle
décide de tout tout seul
nous serons actionnaires minoritaires
donc le département en tant
qu'institution présidera le conseil
d'admistration ena surveillera cette
société pour s'assurer que la qualité
l'écoutent
tout choix bien cadré est bien conforme
au cahier des charges
plusieurs garanties comme l'utilisation
de 20 % de produits bio le respect de la
saisonnalité ou encore le suivi de la
traçabilité des denrées
la réforme sera mise en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2019
pour cette rentrée 2010 8 la région
ile-de-france veut que ces lycéens
d'enjeux mieux on veut du produit local
et puis on veut que dans ce produit
local 50% soit du produit bio donc nous
allons travailler sur cet
approvisionnement senlis et cette année
seront concernés par l'introduction du
bio
l'augmentation des tarifs pour les
parents qui règne le repas de leurs
enfants suivant leur quotient familial
alors pour aider les lycées la région
finance à 40 % les produits bio et la 60
% de bio local au lycée 17 mar de
maurepas on essaie de servir du bio
depuis six ans objectif d'ici la fin de
l'année atteints dans les 10 % de
produits bio dans les plateaux pour
obtenir ces produits locaux le lycée
fait appel au groupement des
agriculteurs bio d'île de france
mais ce n'est pas toujours suffisant et
des moments où ils ont pas forcément
alors soit parce qu'on est trop nombreux
à recommander ou ou que les vaches n'ont
pas donné assez de lait et la semaine
dernière je n'ai pas eu toute ma
livraison
ils ont partagé quoi pour tout le monde
puisse en avoir et pas du tout la
livraison de yao fait j'avais demandé
qu'on a le plus de mal à trouver c'est
la viande car quand on parle
restauration scolaire on parle quantité
on passe à peu près 300 personnes en une
demi heure au maximum ce sont 600 repas
qui sont servis chaque jour d'ouverture
de la demi-pension au lycée jules ferry
de versailles
on explose les compteurs 1300 élèves
sont inscrits à la cantine
la plus grosse difficulté c'est de
trouver des agriculteurs ou des
commerçants qui sont prêts à jouer le
jeu sur le volume puisque si on prend
l'exemple des pommes de terre
aujourd'hui on est sur 350 kg de pommes
de terre pour servir autant de repas pas
moins de 200 fait une organisation bien
rodée donc notre cuisine fait une
production à la minute au fur à mesure
que les élèves amans soult les personnes
qui sont à l'abomination annonce on leur
fait de la production on réajuste au
plus près de façon à ne pas perdre le
gâchis et avant produits sains et de
qualité servie chanteur ici le mot
d'ordre est locale le chef de cuisine
s'est rapproché de ses collègues investi
par les mêmes envies de circuits courts
pour créer un réseau en 2012 nous avons
monté l'action toqués du local qui était
d'une réfection de consommer des
produits qu'on trouvait au sol de nous
en ile de france puisque bien souvent on
va chercher des produits très loin alors
que en ile de france et un de très bons
produits
que ce soit dans le volet emploi ont
fouillé légumes en produits laitiers
ce jour là c'est la fête de la
gastronomie l'occasion parfaite de
mettre en avant des produits les plus
locaux possibles des moules de normandie
des produits laitiers de la ferme de
grignon et du raisin français de
différentes variétés
moi je vous fais un assortiment allez on
se fait ça au total 20 % des lycéens
franciliens ont des produits bio dans
leurs plateaux
[Musique]
manger sain et local dans les
restaurants universitaires c'est le pari
lancé par les crous de france dans
l'ensemble de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
dix-huit mille repas par jour sont
servis à 3000 étudiants et rien que sur
ce site de guyancourt jusqu'à 500 repas
sont vendus quotidiennement dans une
telle cadence le crous de versailles
tente de s'engager dans une démarche
nutritionnelle scène c'est une même
politique qui est surtout basé sur la
qualité du produit et la valorisation du
fait maison
les repas sont élaborés par des chefs de
cuisine dans des cuisines pour chaque
site
on n'a pas de cuisine centrale on
fabrique directement et on serrait il a
le choix il l'a toujours un féculent il
a toujours un légume
il a des crudités il a des fruits il a
des laitages du fromage il a le choix
souvent déjà d'une viande ou d'un
poisson
le crous est attentif à l'équilibré
entre étudiants et l'offre
traditionnelle permet pour 3 euros 25 à
chaque étudiant de bénéfices et d'un
repas équilibré complet chaque fois en
tant qu'établissement public le crous
doit respecter le principe des marchés
publics et s'approvisionner donc auprès
de fournisseurs homologué à l'issue
d'une procédure de mise en concurrence
les achats par contre sont basées sur
des marchés publics qui sont soit
locaux c'est-à-dire pour l'académie de
versailles soit nationaux pour
l'ensemble des douze nos critères sont
basées majoritairement sur la qualité un
de nos marchés en régionale et le marché
des fruits et légumes et que à partir de
la semaine prochaine on lance une une
quinze jours sur le local et de manière
plus ponctuelle ce crous s'approvisionne
auprès de circuits courts
par exemple pour la semaine du goût
on va avoir le thème cette année c'est
le local donc on va faire intervenir des
producteurs franciliens
une recette qui semble faire l'unanimité
chez les étudiants de ce resto u de
saint quentin en yvelines
il ya plusieurs choix entrée chaude les
poissons les desserts et pâtisseries des
yaourts des fruits
j'avais un peu peur de la cantine ce
bout parce que laure j'avais j'avais
essayé tout aimé par oui ou non mes
restos revenir ch est déjà passé par là
c'est super veille à bout et rejoint en
avons le choix un choix alimentaires
essentiels pour cette population qui se
nourrit mal un étudiant sur cinq saute
au moins un repas dans la journée et 14%
d'entre eux ne mangent ni fruits ni
légumes
[Musique]
voilà pour ce premier dossier à de la
saison la rédaction vous donne rendez
vous chaque jour de la semaine pour
suivre l'actualité vous pouvez également
revoir nos sujets sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile et
puis bien sûr elle est commentée laissez
vos appréciations sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]